vamos a hablar de la mafia actual la que
en algún momento conocimos por los
grandes ecapos y que el terror que
generaban en las principales ciudades
donde operaban atrás parecen haber
entonces quedado estas prácticas en la
actualidad son organizaciones que buscan
cada vez más pasar desapercibidas y
poder operar sin ser detectadas vamos a
saludar entonces a nuestro primer
invitado el día Íñigo Domínguez el
periodista del país de España
especialista en temas sobre la mafia
Íñigo Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 hablemos
entonces de la mafia actual en
comparación de la mafia como la
conocíamos anteriormente porque traemos
también este tema hoy en directo América
de Francia 24 puede ser por la captura
de Mateo messina esté el líder de la
cosa nostra que tenía pues ya 30 años
prófugo de la justicia en Italia era el
criminal más buscado de ese país
sí es es
interesante comparar la idea que tenemos
de la magia sobre todo a través de las
películas que todos hemos visto y luego
como es realmente siempre hay un
desajuste cuando en la realidad se abren
paso las noticias y tenemos que ajustar
ese enfoque no Aunque siempre hay una
parte de conexión muy curiosa como en
este caso que Mateo Messi la de naro ya
hoy sabemos que en su habitación tenía
un póster de Marlon Brando en El Padrino
Entonces
esta esta mezcla de
imagen de mitos y de lo que es realmente
siempre la tenemos no en este caso como
explicabas lo que nos hace ver
la importancia en medicina del aro ha
sido durante 30 años desaparecido el
último superviviente del Clan más
sanguinario de la O sea nuestra
siciliana que era el clan de los
corleoneses durante 30 años no se sabía
ni la cara que tenía porque de hecho
solo se manejaban re robots nunca había
estado en prisión es un campo muy
anómalo Respecto a los anteriores porque
era más joven la otra generación también
le gustaba divertirse tuvo varias
amantes en contra de los que ha puesto
adicionales que tenían un sentido pues
más de la familia más de más también de
respetar Incluso un aspecto religioso
cuando él se declaraba ateo
era un campo anómalo y sobre todo su
gran diferencia como comentabas con con
la línea tradicional de la Mafia es que
ha sido el principal exponente en las
últimas décadas de una mafia que se
hacía invisible es decir que como como
alternativa a una derrota que sufrió el
plan de losarloneses en los años 90
Cuando decidió enfrentarse al propio
estado italiano con una guerra declarada
de atentados grandes masacres y
asesinatos de jueces periodistas
magistrados tras ser Derrotado por el
arresto de sus principales Campos entre
una fase de invisibilidad de estar
sumergida de hacer ver como que no
existían para dedicarse a los negocios y
dejar de disparar que es lo que más
alarma crea también no entonces esa fase
ha sido muy fructífera para cosa nuestra
porque de hecho es como una gran empresa
multinacional de blanqueo de dinero que
está en todos los mercados en todos los
mercados de algo ilegal principalmente
en narcotráfico armas residuos etcétera
no pero que ya se mimatiza con empresas
de aspecto legal en las que ellas están
detrás no de todo tipo de vecina de Nava
invertido en energía eólica en
obviamente en cualquier empresa que opte
a concursos públicos de agua de sanidad
de servicio de basuras y luego contaba
con una complicidad
en el territorio en el que estaba en
sicilia Pues que es su territorio donde
hay una burguesía mafiosa Aparentemente
ciudadano normales que son su caldo de
cultivo Íñigo Cómo llegan a este punto
digamos de permearse tanto en la
sociedad para allá aparecer casi que una
organización legal no está como como lo
estábamos hablando y también hay un
punto importante que quisiéramos que que
quisiera que hiciéramos una comparación
y ese de la mafia Europea de todo lo que
estamos hablando allá en Europa sobre
todo en Italia y también en comparación
con latinoamérica la mexicana recordemos
que hace poco también fue detenido en un
pues operativo policial de película casi
no uno de los hijos del Chapo Guzmán El
que heredó básicamente su negocio en
México Si vemos un poco también de esto
de la mafia antigua de balaceras de
atentados sobre todo también contra la
prensa Entonces qué comparación podemos
hacer entre la mafia Europea y la mafia
latinoamericana sobre todo la mexicana
bien hablar de magia europea claro visto
Desde allí Europa es muy pequeñita y
hablando de esta mafia puede ser europea
La Mafia la que pertenece Mateo messina
de naro es cosa nuestra siciliana que es
de sicilia que es algo muy concreto y
digamos que además es quien tiene la
patente de la franquicia de la marca esa
marca tan terrorífica de Mafia No que la
mafia mafia es una palabra siciliana que
nace en el siglo XIX y bueno
inaugura esta este crimen organizado por
desgracia tan exitoso no luego ha habido
otras mafias en Italia que ha ido
surgiendo la camorra en la zona de
Nápoles en drungueta en la zona de
calabria que es la punta de la bota de
Italia para entendernos y esta mafia en
tranqueta es la más peligrosa y la más
en este momento no cosa nuestra digamos
que está declive desde los 90 sigues
sigue siendo muy presente pero la
primación ahora mismo es del andranqueta
que es la que domina el narcotráfico y
la que tiene los acuerdos con con narco
tanto en los carteles en Colombia en
México y es su interlocutor en Europa
por otra parte la entrada que también
cosa nueva camorra ya funcionan como
empresas transnacionales desde hace
mucho tiempo pero beneficiadas por esta
invisibilidad están en bueno en toda
Europa por supuesto pero también en
Canadá en Australia bueno en Estados
Unidos desde el siglo
XIX pero
solo en Italia y esta conciencia de su
peligrosidad y de su capacidad de
corromper y de ser un cáncer social no
sobre todo de corrupción de las
instituciones públicas en el resto de
Europa pese a estar muy presente desde
los 80 90
la guardia está muy baja precisamente
por esta invisibilidad está muy
presentes en el territorio solo emergen
de vez en cuando cuando se arresta a un
capo y en ese país de repente se
asombran de que hay un mafioso viviendo
allí Aunque a lo mejor lleva 20 años
pero es precisamente ese aspecto de
aparentar ser empresarios de vida
Aparentemente normal el que les hace
estar muy muy minimatizados su éxito
radica Precisamente en tener grandes
cantidades de liquidez de dinero para
invertir y mezclarse con otros
empresarios legales en los que
simplemente
para ellos es un empresario italiano con
mucho dinero dispuesto a invertir y
hacer negocio